chaque année le nombre des consultations
médicales augmente de 10 % derrière
cette consommation accrue derrière la
sécurité sociale et son déficit
gigantesque il y a le problème numéro un
de toutes les nations modernes définir
une politique de santé
il ne faut pas nous demandons que cela
que tout serait de leur a paru simple
loi et par un acte unique
c'est un édifice
il faut ajouter les pierres les unes aux
autres
la caisse nationale de son côté a dit
responsable dans violations
s'invectivent le tas gouvernement le
parlement dire que l'assurance maladie
coûte trop cher parce que les médecins
et les malades abusent c'est peut-être
un tout petit peu vrai mais c'est en
grande partie de la mythologie dire par
contre que le coût de la santé
augmentent parce que le progrès
technique
l'accroissement démographique pour
réguler turrel progrès social provoque
une augmentation de la paie l'eau soit
errants curable des maladies qu'il
n'était pas ça c'est la réalité
on dit aussi que les médecins sont en
querelles permanentes avec l'assurance
maladie
ces dames et hull par contre 93 % des
médecins français ont signé des
conventions collectives ou individuelles
avec l'assurance maladie
ça c'est la réalité pour la sécurité
sociale il est nécessaire de faire des
économies mais de part et d'autre
n'existe-t-il pas des abus c'est pas sa
propre corps médical a été attaqué ce
n'est pas une question de style it et de
lui mais nous voulons l'amener et nous
avons probablement cassé convaincant
puisque l'unanimité du conseil
ministration de la caisse nationale
maladie et d'un c'était à l'esprit qu'il
faut maintenant faire comprendre aux
médecins qu'ils ont des responsabilités
économiques dans la prescription
il faut ils en prennent conscience quels
remèdes appliqués créer des impôts
nouveaux
rationaliser l'hospitalisation et
l'industrie pharmaceutique
augmenter les cotisations sociales des
plus hauts salaires
autant de points d'interrogation pour
assainir il faudrait d'abord que
la sécurité sociale et des financements
qui correspond à ses besoins des besoins
de santé sont prioritaires nos médecins
nous sommes des fabricants de vieillards
des fabricants handicapés puisque nous
permettant aux gens de vivre et
quelquefois dans des conditions
relativement difficile puisqu'on les a
empêché de mourir
le progrès technique nous donne des
devoirs devant lesquels nous devons nous
soumettre nous médecins
il est donc normal qu'ils un financement
supérieur est en est que les services
que rend l'assurance maladie à travers
la médecine sont supérieurs à ce qui
était prévu en 1945 ceci dit on ne peut
pas dire que tout se passe pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes
la santé la médecine sont devenus dedans
et si coûteuse aussi précieuse que
personne a droit de gâcher